almost starring in alias ruling the
poker tables in edinburgh and lollipops
for the homeless maybe there's more to
the woman behind pam from the office
than you thought here's the untold truth
of jenna fisher
growing up in st louis jenna fischer's
idol was her mother anne who often acted
in church plays while fisher and her
sister emily helped her memorize her
lines and taught five-year-old fisher in
an acting workshop at her school and two
important things happened first while
pretending a toy mailbox was a
microphone made the future office star
realize that she could be an actor
secondly she met a boy in that class
named sean gunn years later when she ran
into gun on a visit home after she had
moved to los angeles he told her he was
going out to start his own acting career
once out there he helped her make a
number of vital contacts he got her into
an acting showcase that garnered the
attention of the person who would become
their manager jump-starting her career
he also introduced her to his brother
james the director who would later
become fisher's husband even after they
split fisher remained friends with the
gunn brothers
jenna fisher told st louis art's channel
hectv that when she first arrived in
hollywood she may have had an
unrealistic view of how soon she'd find
success i'm gonna make it in six months
and
it was
it was all not six months in fact she
went on to say that at that point she
was in debt with no agent and horrible
head shots she described herself as
naive and wished she had a mentor who
would have helped her navigate things
that's why she wrote the actor's life a
survival guide it's not a book about
learning how to act but a book about
learning how to navigate the business of
acting here she points out for example
that only five percent of screen actors
guild members make over a hundred
thousand dollars a year the median is 52
000
and that's before agent and manager fees
even getting to the point where you have
an agent is a difficult process fisher
also dishes out tips and advice based on
her own experiences and talks a lot
about food and taking advantage of
buffets and urges actors to save food
for later prior to her breakthrough role
in the office fisher wrote directed and
starred in her own film a mockumentary
called lolly love co-starring her then
husband director james gunn it depicted
a rich couple attempting to improve the
lives of homeless people by giving them
lollipops with uplifting messages on
them co-starring acting friends like
judy greer linda cardellini and jason
siegel it gave fisher a leg up on the
cringe comedy of mockumentaries fisher
earned a screen actors guild emerging
actor award at her hometown st louis
film festival for the project and she
also received the troma dance kodak
independent soul award presented to
deserving directors of independent films
of the experience fischer told playback
it was a lot of hard work the directing
was exhausting and the writing was
painful it was very difficult to direct
and star in a movie she added that the
crew was so small in the movie that she
ended up having to fill even more roles
besides acting and directing even having
to serve lunch she summed it up by
saying i'm good at multitasking but that
was too much for me i couldn't enjoy any
one part the way i would have liked i
think i'll stick to acting that part was
fantastic
in episode 43 of their podcast office
ladies jenna fisher brought up to her
co-host angela kinsey that she
auditioned for the role of sydney
bristow on the television series alias
fisher recalled that the scene she did
during her audition was extremely
dramatic and emotional but ultimately it
didn't land her the role for a really
disappointing reason saying the feedback
that my agent got was like jenna blew us
away we absolutely loved it her scene
was she just did a great job we're gonna
pass on her because we just
unfortunately don't think she's hot
enough that was my feedback happily all
of this was followed by fisher and
kinsey discussing their idea of doing a
mom detective show where they went
around and solved minor crimes of course
if fischer had gotten the alias role she
never would have had a shot at being pam
beasley
on the office star brian baumgardner's
podcast an oral history of the office
the former kevin malone actor
interviewed jenna fisher about her
audition process casting director alison
jones told her in no uncertain terms to
play the part very real even going on to
say in fact jenna dare to bore me fisher
had been a fan of the original of the
office from england and the character of
dawn and she knew that her character had
similar beats at the same time she added
her own experience as a receptionist
before she got her big break in
hollywood to create pam's backstory in
her mind and she used that in her
audition when series showrunner greg
daniels interviewed her as though he was
a documentarian he was stunned to see
how realistic her performance was
especially when he asked if she liked
working as a secretary to which she
simply and wearily replied no several
seconds of silence followed and the rest
is history i hope they get rid of me
because then i might actually get off my
ass and do something
when the office was still in the
audition process jenna fischer was
paired with john krasinski as her scene
partner they quickly developed an easy
chemistry and fisher was delighted when
she learned both had nailed down their
roles after two seasons where the show
grew in popularity and the aching
sweetness between the characters of jim
and pam left viewers looking for hopeful
signs things shockingly came to a head
in the season 2 finale perhaps the
single most important episode of the
entire series i was just um
i'm in love with you
what
director ken kwapis noted that they only
used a single camera to record the scene
with their first kiss and kept it away
from the actors giving the real sense of
eavesdropping for the viewers in the
office ladies podcast episode discussing
the show jenna fischer and john
krazinski revealed that they were kept
away from each other for an hour before
the scene to add to its nervous
intensity fisher said we never rehearsed
it on stage together and i remember they
brought me to set all the lights were
dim there was no one around it was super
eerie their sixth season wedding episode
was also a monumental event even being
shot on location in niagara falls
balancing an episode where the premise
wasn't necessarily funny with the cringe
humor associated with the show was a
difficult task at one point writer greg
daniels was pushing for pam's ex-fiance
roy to show up on a horse and object to
the wedding later when pam would flatly
turn him down he was going to leave the
horse there even later dwight would ride
on the horse and it would accidentally
go over the edge of the falls this
bizarre idea got a cold reception with
daniels recalling the entire staff and
actors were yelling at me don't ruin jim
and pam's wedding with a horse instead
they substituted the dunder mifflin
employees recreating the viral video of
a family doing a dance to chris brown's
forever the genius of the episode was
that jim and pam had anticipated their
friends interfering with their wedding
with these kinds of antics so their
actual ceremony was on a water-swept
boat moments before
fisher's known for her side-eye
exasperation and fairly conservative
wardrobe from the office certain films
however have seen her playing against
type in the 2007 figure skating spoof
blades of glory fisher plays katie van
waldenberg the younger sister of the
sinister skating siblings played by amy
poehler and will arnett there's a scene
where she's sent to seduce will
ferrell's character in order to break up
his skating duo but they can't quite go
through with it
hey i didn't sleep with katie i know we
didn't even get the second base well
maybe i did
she later reflected on the part saying i
definitely challenged myself in ways in
this movie that i think will be a
stepping stone for me trying to spread
my wings in 2007's walk hard the dewey
[ __ ] story fisher plays darlene madison
one of dewey's backup singers who
eventually tempts him into cheating on
his wife fisher said playing darlene was
liberating noting it got kind of cool to
just flaunt it and not care and be in
the spotlight jenna fisher actually
wasn't supposed to appear in
then-husband james gunn's first film
2006's slither gunn had cast a male
actor to play the role of police
dispatcher shelby but he begged off at
the last moment gunn then gender-swapped
the role and gave it to fisher adding a
few more scenes as she became one of
many victims of an alien hive mind by
the time the movie debuted fisher had
suddenly become famous thanks to the
success of season two of the office and
she wound up doing a lot of publicity
for slither after she and gunned
divorced fisher met screenwriter lee
kirk in 2008 and he pitched her an idea
that became the film the giant
mechanical man a quirky love story that
they developed together this was her
first producing credit and she also
starred in the movie as they nurtured
the product through the national
financial collapse in 2008 they fell in
love got married and had a child after
years of delays the actual shoot was
just 19 days fisher joked about her
marriage after the movie was completed
saying i don't know what we're going to
talk about anymore because for the last
four years we've been talking about the
giant mechanical man
fischer started her career on the stage
and she's had a number of opportunities
to get back to her roots while the
office was starting to wind down she
worked with her husband lee kirk in a
2010 revival of his absurdist play sad
happy sucker workshopped three years
earlier fischer put on her producer hat
as kirk directed it at the lyric
hyperion theater as the office was
airing its final episode in may of 2013
fisher debuted in the off-broadway
production reasons to be happy written
by neil labute labute personally offered
her the role and also directed the play
which ran for a month as a result fisher
wasn't able to watch the finale of the
office with her old castmates but former
co-star bj novak was in new york and
came out to support her in 2016 fisher
co-starred in steve martin's play meteor
shower about a couple attending a meteor
shower viewing party at another couple's
house it set a box office record at san
diego's old globe theater making nearly
one million dollars over its six-week
run fisher played corki who has the
cracks in her marriage undermined and
exposed by the other party guests
playing poker has become one of jenna
fisher's many hobbies when she and lee
kirk went on their honeymoon to scotland
in 2010 they tried to beat their jetlag
by staying up just late enough to wake
up bright and early the next day in an
effort to stay awake they wandered
around edinburgh and happened upon a pub
holding a poker tournament they both
entered and kirk did well finishing
fifth however they didn't leave just yet
because fisher was doing even better as
she told hemispheres somehow through a
combination of weariness adrenaline
caffeine and a little alcohol i was
playing the best poker of my life my
instincts were heightened i seemed to
have a perfect read on every player at
the table my stat growing with every
hand i felt like i was floating in some
kind of european poker heaven fisher won
it all and the couple then went back to
their hotel and collapsed she's even
brought her skills to the show celebrity
poker showdown
when jenna fischer starred in the 2011
movie hall pass she made an instant
connection with her co-star christina
applegate the movie is about two married
men who get a hall pass from their wives
for a week meaning they can do anything
they want including seeing other people
of course that means their wives played
by fisher and applegate get to play as
well speaking about applegate to
collider fisher said what happened
immediately is that christina and i
clicked like two peas in a pod we just
had the best time every time we were on
set together we hung out the whole time
while fisher praised the overall
chemistry of the ensemble she also felt
like applegate was her teammate in a
competition saying when it was finally
time to do our scenes with the four of
us together we really did have a boys
against the girls chemistry going we
were a force to be reckoned with after
the office ended in 2013 fisher's career
slowed and after having a second child
in 2014 she was limited to guest
starring jobs however she landed the
part of andy burns the wife of matt
leblanc on his show man with a plan she
was hoping the cbs show would be her
next long-running role on the day the
show was announced she got a phone call
and i said i said it's bad news isn't it
and they said yeah and i said we didn't
get picked up
and they were like no
it's worse
the show in fact did get picked up for
more episodes however after showing the
episodes to focus groups they decided
that fisher wasn't right for the part
and fired her watching it later she
realized the focus groups that said they
didn't believe pam and joey as a couple
actually might have been right admitting
we kind of seemed like two people doing
good performances and they were both
quite good shows but they weren't the
same show leblanc's show lasted four
seasons before being cancelled in 2020.
fischer was replaced by lysa snyder but
she went on to have a solid two-year run
on splitting up together
it only lasted ten episodes but jenna
fischer had a compelling role in the
2015 nbc science fiction comedy series
you me and the apocalypse the show
centers around an ensemble cast reacting
to the knowledge that an asteroid will
be hitting earth in about a month
causing the end of the world fisher
plays ronda a seemingly mild-mannered
librarian who's in prison she was sent
there for hacking into the nsa but she
only did it to protect her son a hacker
springs her from prison and she becomes
the sidekick to a white nationalist
played by megan mullally this sure took
the role after taking time off following
the birth of her daughter of the show's
bizarre premise she told the los angeles
times i get to do stunts and be in
shootouts i take someone hostage at one
point i never get asked to do stuff like
that because no one wants to see pam
doing that so it was fun
after her role as pam it can be hard to
picture jenna fisher in a gritty action
drama but she had a memorable role in
clint eastwood's 2018 action thriller
the 1517 to paris a dramatization of
real-life events the movie depicts the
events surrounding an incident when
three americans disarmed and detained an
armed terrorist on a train in france
fisher played a mother to one of the men
appearing in dramatizations of their
childhood fisher has entered the part of
her career where she's playing these
older maternal roles but playing it
seriously was something new for her at
eastwood she said every story you have
heard about working for clint eastwood
is absolutely true he's prepared he's
efficient he's inspirational he gives
great acting notes it's crazy that his
crew has been working with him so long
they have a short hand so the day goes
by very quickly
jenna fisher and angela kinsey may have
been adversaries on the office but in
real life they became immediate best
friends both kept detailed journals and
memos of their office experience as they
were looking through boxes of
memorabilia kinsey told vulture i said
to her i really wanted to rewatch the
show fully i hadn't done that since we
made the show and neither did jenna so
we collectively had this why don't we do
this moment why not it's the anniversary
so let's reminisce and share the
memories with the fans and thus office
ladies was born their natural chattiness
translated perfectly over to the podcast
format while they do go through a
detailed exploration of each episode
their frequent tangents and debates set
it apart from similar office related
media i was driving yesterday and i was
chewing a piece of gum i was popping my
gum
and i bit the sh taki out of my tongue
it's so bad look at it it only makes
sense that the success of the office
ladies podcast led to a book titled the
office bffs tales from the office from
two best friends who were there the book
covers a lot of the same ground as the
podcast what the book really brings is
some of the things alluded to on the
podcast like both star's detailed
journaling as well as scores of photos
recording their experiences while
working the office was famous for making
its background actors safe for every
scene because they were pretending to
film a real office this resulted in
background actors needing to find ways
to amuse themselves and it's one of the
things that led to fisher and kinsey
becoming friends fisher said the bonding
began after the basketball episode from
the first season when they sat on a
bench next to each other for two days
they got giddy at the end skipping
across the parking lot arm and arm star
steve carell saw them and fisher
remembered he said no matter what
happens this is what you'll take with
you this and he pointed at the two of us
he was so right
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite sitcom stars are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]